in this episode of cloud performance
Alice I helped some cloudy file servers
clear their performance thoughts will
they see clearly once the fog is gone
stay tuned to find out
Nimbus disk is a cloud-based file system
company who was having some trouble with
their persistent disk performance huh
they tried all the usual suggestions
like analyzing disk size and CPU count
but still weren't seeing the performance
they wanted and while digging around for
other things they might be able to try I
actually stumbled into this little gem
it says the default block size on
volumes is 4k for throughput oriented
workloads values of 256 K are
recommended now unbeknownst to me this
single sentence was exactly what was
causing the Nimbus disk woes so
generally speaking when it comes to disk
operations a block is the smallest unit
of data that is read during an i/o
operation so if you're trying to read 5
bytes and your block size is 512 bytes
the entire 512 bytes will be read from
disk even though your application will
only use 5 bytes from it so with this in
mind it's important to observe the
following formula with respect to disk
performance now how this evens out is
that the AI ops and the block size tend
to have an inverse relationship to each
other as block size increases it takes
longer to read a single block and thus
the number of AI ops decreases inversely
small block size yields higher ions to
figure out how GC pees persistent disks
behave as the block size changed I set
up a simple 32 core machine with a one
terabyte standard persistent disk
attached to it and tested the
performance against block sizes what we
see expectedly is that V as the window
size grows RI ops get lower and our
throughput gets higher likewise we can
do the same test for an SSD persistent
disks and we see a similar reduction in
AI ops as block size increases but by
the way that that hard cap you see for
throughput at 16 K window size is
actually a function of the testing
config I was using a by increasing our
PD SSD side or moving to 64 cores we
should be able to remove that limit
now here's the important part by default
GCPs persistent disks use a block size
of 4k which is perfect for higher I ops
workloads like relational databases
nimbus disk however was much more
concerned with throughput which meant
they wanted to be on the other side of
the block size window with a simple
config change to move to a one megabyte
block size their per fin creased about
30x not bad for a simple command line
flag if you'd like to know more about
this problem check out the article
listed in the description below and
don't forget to check out the rest of
the cloud performance Atlas content
because when it comes to performance
every millisecond counts